this is a funny little side story about
Donald Trump that just serves as a good
opportunity to remind everybody in the
audience about what's really an
undeniable reality which is that most
welfare recipients in the United States
are white people in light of Trump's
recent [ __ ] country comments and
interrupting a Korean American
intelligence analyst to demand that she
tell him where her parents are from NBC
News put together a sort of Greatest
Hits list for Trump which shows
basically that the guy's been
insensitive on race for a very very long
time and one of the most cringe-worthy
examples from the report is that back in
March Donald Trump invited to the White
House members of the Congressional Black
Caucus and Trump started this gong show
by asking all the black lawmakers in the
room whether they knew ben Carson who's
the lone black guy on Trump's cabinet
according to two people who were in the
room Trump was reportedly surprised that
he had a room full of black people
members of Congress and none of them
knew ben Carson that now that's already
funny right but then later in this
meeting with the Congressional Black
Caucus the topic turns to the cutting of
welfare programs and one of the members
of the Congressional Black Caucus said
that hey listen if you cut welfare
programs that's going to hurt my
constituents quote not all of whom are
black this apparently blew Trump's mind
who then responded by saying really then
what are they so Trump is yes he's
ignorant and he lacks decorum and he
lacks class but lots of people imagine
the welfare recipient of the United
States as black or at least not a white
person and statistically welfare
recipients are most likely to be white
white people are the biggest recipients
of aid from programs like TANF which is
often what people talk about when
they're when they're saying welfare
that's what they're talking about also
applies to snap food stamp benefits
white people without college degrees in
particular age 18 to 64 are the biggest
recipients of these programs so we've
before we move on from the truck part
Trump really wants to do welfare reform
very important he's a fiscal
conservative and meanwhile he thinks
most welfare recipients are black this
shouldn't change anything
right what I mean is in an ideal world
you wouldn't decide to cut or boost
welfare based on the racial makeup of
the recipients but it's another example
of trumps bluster and arrogance on
issues that he knows nothing about this
is the result of Trump being glued to
the dog whistling of Fox News for what
is probably over a decade at this point
and it's not a coincidence that people
like Trump have this association between
welfare and black people that is a
feature not a bug is the phrase I like
to apply to it it's by design right and
it relates to these coherent narratives
that humans look for and why facts often
don't change people's minds dissonant
facts I mentioned this earlier in the
show dissonant facts become exceptions
to the rules rather than changing
people's views of what the rules are and
then by the way personal welfare aside
of course most government handouts
subsidies and benefits are going to rich
people and to big corporations
particularly under Donald Trump's plan
so just another embarrassing day in the
era of Trump with the entire [ __ ] hole
country's comments but if there's any
upside to it it's that it has triggered
all sorts of other stories and anecdotes
about Trump that were previously unknown
and each is more concerning than the
last